je sais pas où on est mais à mon avis vu
le climat et la végétation
on n'est pas loin d'angoulême ou un truc
comme ça
un nom l'ohl
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien faire tout en noir mais tout
ce qu'ils font c'est toujours grand
toujours plus gros plus grands c'est
incroyable à l'eau des grands arbres les
grosses voitures
les grosses commandes
[Musique]
obama
les brouillages
[Musique]
au numéro de maison et des baraques pas
trop mal c'est que m
yann qui m'aidait de yahoo qui met du
domicile au indy lights
on a perdu nous les leçons de l'histoire
alors ici on est où on a un magasin
américain devrait découvrir ensemble
toute la culture américaine et les beaux
produits du terroir allez c'est parti
non ce n'est pas du pâté pour chien
c'est toujours bon pour les humains les
quatre litres de jus d'orange très
typique où les quatre litres de judo de
jus d'orange périmés et non ceci n'est
pas un coup de peinture mais de la
margarine américaine aussi à l'aise sur
tartines
q dans la poêle et 100 acrylique je
venais à l'instar h avec un gros comme
ça
ozil je vais à la maison de tom
cruise l'acteur américain et je suis un
peu entre est ce parce que j'ai peur qui
les gardiens et les chiens de traîneaux
qui vient de manger
ok on arrive où on arrive
ouais tu quand est ce qu'on va faire je
le dis on va partir oui bonjour ce
serait pour rencontrer tom cruise normal
on a des cookies bon
ok mais apparemment ça a l'air d'être
difficile de rencontrer de tom cruise
j'ai peut-être une autre solution pour
rencontrer des stars
m
[Musique]
weeks 10 secondes
tadic y est
michel blanc
[Applaudissements]
comme les stars c'est pas des vrais les
gens et fait des fautes ou d'extrêmement
près stationner
[Musique]
eh bien
ici on le club de patins à roulettes de
los angeles
alors si vous aimez écouter du disco
rires entre amis et puis également ride
et un peu sur un parquet parfaitement
lisse c'est possible et tout en même
temps
allez je vais rater ouais
toute façon - là bas je suis plus tout
ce qui est trottinette cet aprem en à
hollywood pour visiter les studios de
cinéma malheureusement n'a pas votre
film est donc on a fait des photos quand
même dans le parking la barrière là
ressemble à un clap de cinéma c'est
assez énorme bond sur la fontaine n'ai
pas pu m'empêcher de faire un trois
philippins skate même essence kate ça
c'est le banc de tom hanks dans le film
forrest gump
je me suis assis dessus et ça m'a rien
fait de spécial alors on a fait le stage
quatre stages 5
ça c'est le stage 18 il était vraiment
sympa là derrière ce décor est en train
de se filmer une scène de malades d'un
gros films américains à gros budget mais
du coup on a laissé derrière à admirer
l'arrière du décor on a même vu le
château d'eau de cette marque typique
n'a pas raté
évidemment pour la vidéo on avait des
petites oreilles est plutôt ringarde
là c'est le moment de la visite que
j'étais carrément content et puis à la
fin il y avait même une grande rue avec
mark et olly ou de loin alors on a pris
une photo
et puis on est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très très bon avis aux amateurs venus
il pourra petites infos los angeles
seydoux soit naïve et paris ça c'est une
info à sortir avec une petite saucisse
cocktail en apéro l'air de rien
[Musique]
vous calmez vous les gars moi si
désespérant aux lignes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici sur la plage de venice beach
los angeles que se termineront tour du
monde
cette fabuleuse aventure
guillaume
vraiment très beau parcours
on va bientôt
à paris
il faut que je rentre
d'une manière ou d'une autre d'une
manière ou d'une autre